what you want if you're a guy like urban
meyer who was a legendary coach in
college one of the best of all time
three titles winning titles with two
teams you cannot argue with his success
in college football so for some reason
he thought he was going to try in the
nfl we've discussed him on on several
shows but the one thing you have to do
as a coach like that who comes from
college the one most important thing you
have to do is get the respect of the
players in your locker room it is so
critical because they already judge you
differently you're already a college boy
and you think you're smarter than
everybody because what worked for you at
ohio state and florida you automatically
think's going to work in that locker
room with grown men and it has no chance
of working so you got to earn respect
and what happened to urban meyer this
past week i don't think
got him any respect in the locker room
i'm wondering if you guys think that
there's any uh long lasting
repercussions but here's what happened
so they played the thursday night game
in ohio against cincinnati so he was in
his favorite state there was home state
actually decided to not fly back with
the team which i thought was odd even
though he's from ohio has a house there
has family their grandchildren i thought
it was weird you'd never see that in the
nfl where a head coach doesn't fly back
with the team he didn't he stayed back
ended up at a bar
his bar
okay right ended up on a bar stool that
he owns and a fema a blonde female kind
of grinding into him which
was not part of the script that night
yeah and it showed up on twitter and it
went viral and he had some explaining to
do at home and in the locker room so i
guess the big question is if you're
winning if you're jimmy johnson and this
happened in 1992 it'd be no big deal
people laughing about it and
congratulating and medium out the bar
the next week but for urban meyer this
is probably the last thing he needed do
you think this further shows that this
is it one year and he's probably out of
this nfl experience
yeah
i didn't want to be that way like i was
rooting for urban meyer but swag matters
in the nfl man like for lack of a better
term swag matters dude you can't you
can't rule with an iron fist there's no
recruiting there's no i'm gonna recruit
your next guy there's no do it my way
the highway and the nfl they choose the
highway they say screw you bro i'm gonna
be here you're not uh what are you gonna
do you're gonna bench me play somebody
worse than what lose your job they'll
call a coach's bluff so i think you know
when you do this
you know rules oriented he leans heavy
into the the christian you know uh uh
background and and he's you know
constantly talking about culture
rebuilding own it
yeah and then you know it's it's not
even that he was with the girl it was
like he got clowned by the girl do you
understand what i'm saying like she's
throwing up snapchats like who is this
old guy he keeps flirting with me it's
like that's a bad look it's a bad luck
that's a bad look man like especially
for a guy who's kind of authoritative
with his demeanor
but this is a serious question what do
you think
loses more credibility in the locker
room not flying home on the team playing
or getting caught on social media with
that clip it's both but also if he if
like if if he was swagged out if he was
like yeah you could see some some girl
doing that to john gruden and john grew
and somehow turning this into into
you know john gruden's like hey you know
uh i appreciate you dancing on me but
that lapse my wife just get over there
like
now like he's the man yeah that's right
caliendo would have a funny skit on it
at the very end actually and then you
know somebody asked me you can't get
away with it he doesn't have he doesn't
have the collateral the built up the the
sad puppy the dog with my tail between
my i let my family down i let sad
condoms
exactly it portrays weakness which is
the last thing that you want to do as a
head coach he seemed weak
and jeff to your point you go what what
would be more disrespectful for his team
is the fact that he didn't fly back with
him but now what are you gonna do every
road trip you are on what if another
assistant wants to stay back yeah what
if trevor lawrence wants to stay back
how do you say no because he has an
endorsement deal commercially he has to
shoot how do you say no remember
the locker room too
i agree with you on that he should fly
home and then fly back i'm agreeing with
tom's hands
that's happening sorry
i like it
hey thanks so much for checking out that
short clip from sports now with tom
zenner if you want to see another short
clip click right here or if you want to
see the entire episode click right here
thanks for watching everybody
[Music]